because there are these sort of elements
of Seduction in the conversation between
the serpent and Eve yeah but the Bible
functions like that like the Bible also
will not say something like the serpent
slept with with e but because of the
structure of the conversation you
understand that she is submitting
herself to him like she would to her
husband in a way that suggests a kind of
sexual Union without necessarily having
to
like go into the idea that they actually
United sexually by the way this happens
all the way through Bible and in
positive ways too where for example
Christ uh when he meets a Samaritan
woman the entire structure of the
conversation is one of Christ taking her
as a wife but we know that he didn't
marry her and he didn't have he didn't
sleep with her but it's to signify the
meaning of the of the relationship so we
we have to be careful not to fall into
the same kind of materialism that we're
criticizing when we read these stories
but rather be attentive mostly to what
they're trying to help us understand of
what's going on and let's say the
structure of meaning rather than just
wondering like okay so did Eve really
sleep with the snakes like that that's
not what it says in the in the scripture
but but you can understand that that's
what's going on in terms of a
relationship
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone I am here with Father
Stephen DeYoung who I know needs no
introduction to the people who are
watching my channel father Stephen is a
priest in the antiochian church but he
is also the host of The Lord of spirit
podcast of which you know we're all huge
fans of he's also written several books
and he is key in helping people
re-understand the ancient way of
thinking kind of coming back and
bringing back an integrated Cosmic View
and so we really appreciate father
Stephen coming to talk to us a few
things to say father Stephen is going to
be speaking at the symbolic World Summit
in February we are so excited that that
he is coming it'll be great to everybody
I think there'll be so much like buzz in
the room with Father Stephen there and
then everybody there it's going to be
quite quite crazy and he is also he's
also submitted an article for the
symbolic World Journal which we will be
publishing very soon and that is partly
what we're going to talk about today so
father Stephen thanks for coming back
yeah it's good to be back again
the everything is you know you have the
the Lord of spirits uh conference coming
you publish your recent book Apocrypha
things are just steamrolling ahead with
your your project
yeah there's
I mean I I don't want to give the
impression I'm churning things out but
that's
um you know that there's
I'm in a period of my life where I'm I'm
blessed to be able to be very productive
so I'm trying to
Steward that well because I'm sure there
will come times in my life later where I
won't be able to be as productive as I
am right now
and so before we start the actual
conversation I'd like I want to hear
from you what you think if you've seen
because now Lord of spirits has been
going on for a while with like two years
or a year and a half three years three
years man time just flies like crazy and
have you seen a difference let's say in
people's perceptions like have you kind
of seen a marked change in the way that
people uh perceive the world also
perceive scripture perceive their place
in the tradition since you started the
podcast
I I think so the the thing
I've always liked most
right to be the most flattering thing
has always been like in in
my ministry as a pastor has always been
when I see someone
saying something I said and not
crediting me for it
uh and the reason it's important that
they don't credit me for it is that
they're saying it just
from their own heart and mind right
meaning it's it's
sunk in and they've sort of made it
their own
and so with Lord of spirits
the thing again that that makes me most
happy is not when people sort of fall on
over lord of spirits or you know
whatever but when I see people talking
about
Orthodox Christianity talking about
uh religion and
you could tell that it's been shaped by
sort of the topics we've been talking
about you pick up phrases but they've
internalized it
in a way you know that they don't need
to
give me a footnote that he's really
becoming it's kind of becoming their own
world view and and that's what you're
hoping yeah yeah that it's not well Lord
of spirits said this right but that
you know they say this is what's really
going on you know
um
so that's that's heartening to me
because that's
nothing I do
and I'm sure Father Andrew feels this
way too
uh has ever been about me trying to
raise my own profile or get fans for me
or impress people with how clever I am
um
it's always been about trying to recover
you know in English speaking anglophone
Orthodoxy is so impoverished in terms of
how much of the Orthodox tradition isn't
available to us in our language
and so it's always been about trying to
recover
those things that aren't really lost
it's just we're still kind of in the
mission field stage of Orthodoxy
um and trying to bring those things out
and it's great you know a lot of the you
know a lot of the keys that you've been
offering you know all these the kind of
cosmological keys that that you've been
offering have been really helpful to
people and I'm seeing it you know
Richard Roland and I we just started
this course on Beowulf you know and um
just reading reading the first lines
like the early line just in the the
inter when the they um set up Grendel as
the as the monster like right in the
first part you know it's like you can
just see the world that the the
Anglo-Saxons were living in and it was
really they were lived in a kind of this
kind of cosmic vision of the world and
they you know the obviously Grendel is
is a descendant of Kane he's a he's a
monster he's a giant you know and
and the whole book like actually the
Beowulf is in a larger book which has
like where the manuscript was was in a
larger book which had all these monster
stories in them and it was like you know
uh the the letter of Alexander to
Aristotle there was a legend of Saint
Christopher and that was that it's bit
it's in that that uh book and so you
could just see that uh it's it's making
us notice things that people did the
people people didn't notice before and
realizing oh like this this Vision was
is the one that the ancient had whether
you lived in Constantinople or if you
lived in England you know it was the
cosmic World they lived in yeah yeah and
this is a place where we are sort of
impoverished by modernity where there's
been this this reduction right which
didn't have to be the case
scientific understanding could have been
additive right it could have been
we have this that we already understand
now we have this additional deeper level
of understanding of this part of
right the universe in reality but
instead it was accompanied with this
rejection and idea of replacement that
we can replace
this spiritual wisdom accumulated over
Millennia with
scientific insight
newly gained yeah you know yeah but it
but at that time is is over I mean it's
it's over but a lot of people don't
realize it I think it you know they were
still running on the fumes of the 19th
century it seems like very thin fumes
but still we still are uh but we're at
you know we're on
people that are talking about the things
that you're talking about or I do think
that I'm talking about in some ways are
on the strange Leading Edge even in
terms of you know I don't know if you if
you followed some of the conversations
I've had but I'm in a point now where I
can talk to secular
you know cognitive psychologists or
secular scientists and talking about
demons and angels and talking about
worship and talk about God even and they
just kind of Nod along because they
realize that these the question of
agency you know of transpersonal agency
for example has become inevitable to
deal with like we it's actually even
from a materialist point of view the
idea that agency exists only at the
human level and doesn't
if it scales down into animals but
doesn't scale up into higher
organizations it's like it doesn't even
their own system actually it's it's like
there's this weird superstitious thing
and they're thinking to make prevents
them from wanting to see agency kind of
coming down from above and so so you're
you're in this situation where you know
even like I said even people who
wouldn't call to say they're believer
wouldn't even believe in God or like
yeah well we kind of have to acknowledge
that there are these
these intelligences that are acting on
us
yeah I I think there's always been a
sort of intuitive knowledge of it and
then sort of a denial of it yeah
right then you act as if but then if you
ask me if you believe it like no no I
don't believe that but it's like
strangely enough you still act as if
that that was true in in a lot of these
actions you still act as if these these
things coming from above are real yeah
I've never I've never read
I mean I've read plenty of history books
by outright marxists who are insists
they're doing completely material
history
uh but
it always reads like a story yeah
okay it always you know and if you ask
them they'd say well yes to some extent
you know my book is a false construct
right because they have to like deny
their own
right they see there are things that
work here that there's a pattern and
they're bringing it out through their
work
what they know based on their views
there shouldn't be yeah so they're in
this performative contradiction where
the very the very like decrying of the
pattern like this revolutionary Trope is
itself a story that's as old as you know
the cosmogony and so the idea that that
because they're introducing this
revolutionary kind of it's a
destructoring destructuring uh Trope in
there think that it's not a story it's
like well
it's another myth you know it's like cat
you know uh Saturn castrating his father
that's what you're doing it's not it's
not a big it's not a big surprise like
it's not something you know and so you
you're stuck they're stuck in the
religious world uh ultimately you just
don't realize it yeah yeah and and it's
just sort of known and denied rather
than unknown
all right so the thing I want to talk
about today is something you know you
you keep handing you these amazing
golden keys in my own work I mentioned
before that one of the keys that you
handed me was for years I wanted to
mention Traditions that were kind of
enokian traditions but I knew that the
fathers had put that aside but I also
knew that there were some aspects of it
that were really useful and I knew that
the the problem was like the demon and
Angel the demon and women problem and
then when you handed me the ritual part
of it where you said you know these are
just rituals it is it is true it is
actually happening but it's happening
through ritual proxy and that is how
these things get embedded in the world I
was like oh my goodness you just handed
me
the best key even for my own work and
since then I've been like willing to
talk about these things more openly uh
but now you've handed me another like
key which is that
okay so so so I want you actually you I
want you to lay out your theory because
it has to do with a very difficult not
difficult but a a weird passage in the
Book of Genesis when After the flood you
know uh ham discovers his father's
nakedness and and I want you to lay it
out and then we can talk about it
because it's for me it's like a massive
key yeah yeah so there is and it is
weird right it's it's this episode that
comes
um after
After the flood stray is basically over
uh and it seems in certain ways at odds
with the preceding story because the
emphasis of course in the most of the
flood narrative in Genesis six through
nine is that Noah is this one righteous
person
from his generation and then after the
flood you have this whole story with him
becoming drunk and and these other
things unfolding part of the reason it's
so weird is that it's kind of
bodilarized in all the English
translations
um so we weren't getting sort of the
direct and because uh
most English readers aren't
as familiar with the rest of the Torah
as maybe we should be
um so Genesis really is the prologue to
the rest of the the Torah yeah uh and
that's one of the very basic keys to
interpreting and understanding Genesis
if you don't keep that in mind when
you're reading Genesis that this is
leading up to Exodus right this is
leading up to
the rest of of what's in the Torah then
you'll sort of end up misinterpreting it
and so
there's there's a theme here this is the
place where I go to kind of lay it out
because this place where it's most
complete but it's a pattern that repeats
in Genesis and the patriarchal
narratives that make up chapters 12
through 50 of Genesis
um so what's described if you just read
it in English is Noah plants have
Vineyard uh he uh gets drunk in the
vineyard
and his son Ham
sees his father's nakedness his father's
nakedness is uncovered
and uh
goes and tells his brothers
sham and japheth
Shem and japheth go and cover
their father's nakedness and then when
Noah sort of recovers from his
inebriated State he uh curses Canaan
the son of ham who is the fourth son of
his third son and disinherits him so he
disinherits the fourth son of his third
son
uh yeah so definitely already there's a
massive narrative problem and it's a
narrative problem that we gloss over
and I've done it myself we gloss over it
by saying that ham is the cursed one but
that's not what's written in the text
right right and there's all kinds of
bizarre and even racist theories about
the curse of ham yeah and ham is not
cursed
that's right
um yeah so in order to kind of figure
out what's going on here we have to
understand sort of what uncovering the
father's nakedness means
and uh if you go to Leviticus chapter 18
Leviticus chapter 17 through people cut
it off in different places 22 or 23 uh
is What's called the Holiness code
um and has regulations covering holiest
Leviticus 18 is discussing sexual
immorality so that's where the
Commandments are about about sexual
morality
and that takes the form because we're in
a patriarchal society that takes the
form of telling men primarily who
they're not allowed to sleep with
uh because they of course were the ones
making the decisions regarding that
culturally
and
one of those Commandments is
uh you shall not uncover the nakedness
of your father's wife for this is your
father's nakedness
uh and something similar is actually
said about uh your father's daughter
right this is and so this idea it's like
all the incest laws are are are
portrayed as un uncovering your father's
nakedness I think it's even like like
your aunt and like yeah you know your
father's sister yeah yeah
uh and so this phrase of uncovering the
nakedness
right is this reference to sexual
relations
uh particularly that are forbidden right
and you can see why that would be
right the idea is that
um
the Father the patriarch right within
the family is uh
is the one who is charged with
safeguarding in the case of the daughter
in the case of the sister right and even
his own wife safeguarding sort of
protecting uh them from
sexual exploitation from right
um and so it belongs to him and it's his
job to cover it right it's his job to
right sort of protect it
uh so
once you have that in mind
right and we go back to
uh this story in Genesis
uh
what ham is doing here sort of makes
sense
right so we can Now understand
when it says he you know went into his
father's tent
right this is talking and uncovers the
negatives of his father this is him
having relations with his mother
and then
when this comes to the attention
of Noah we see him disinheriting Ham's
youngest son
and why would he need to do that well
Kanan Ham's youngest son is the son he
bore
who his his mother bore him yeah so if
the child conceived
through those illicit sexual relations
uh and the covering of the nakedness is
talking about protecting
that again so the other brothers
once they find out this is going on move
to stop it right move to protect their
mother from
from him their brother ham right and so
the question then becomes sort of why
would ham do this right aside from just
maybe perversion right like why would he
why would he do this
this is actually uh
I don't want to call it an institution
but or a practice but because it was not
well looked at right in the
in the ancient world by the Asian world
and in other places in the scriptures
we see what's called family usurpation
the idea here is that what ham is trying
to do is
he's trying to Bear a son with his
father's wife
who replaced his father right to replace
his father and then that son would
become the heir and so he would be
effectively taking over the family
structure
yeah it's a it's a kind of revolutionary
it's a revolutionary move where he's
trying to take right take he's replaced
his father in terms of authority take
his body like take his take his wife
take his and then also take the
inheritance and take the take everything
away from his father while his father is
still is still alive right right and and
this becomes especially clear when you
know how inheritance and the right of
pretty much editor worked
right the ancient societies which was
first born son inherits everything
yeah and then can choose whether or not
to share that with
the other right Brothers yeah the others
become dependent on him like they become
subsidiary to the older brother right he
takes his father's place when his father
passes away and they have a place of the
extended family only insofar as they're
connected to him and maintain
relationships with him and this is true
throughout the ancient period so even in
the gospels we find someone comes to
Christ
it says teacher tell tell my brother to
divide the inheritance with me right and
Christ says you know you know what don't
worry about the inheritance come follow
me right don't worry about the money but
even there you see how there could be
problems when
first word son just says nah I'm I'm
just going to keep all this and you guys
can
buzz off but so ham would not have
inherited anything
unless he you know maintained this
relationship and remained subsidiary to
his older brother
he then enacts this plan to try to
displace his father and
and take over and that's why then Noah
has to disinherit this child and and
reject it and maybe you can tell people
because obviously it's like okay if
father Stephen just pulling this out of
his hat here uh you know in Genesis
itself and then later in in the Bible
there are examples of that exactly
happening again and so there are places
where this type of behavior is is is
repeated right and and this is just sort
of a clear
case of it but there are other clear
cases I mean later in Genesis uh Reuben
is going to sleep with one of his
father's concubines
to attempt to do this and that's at a
sort of an especially shocking case
because Reuben actually was the
firstborn son yeah
so he's sort of tried to user Jacob
while he's still alive yeah right
um
and Reuben was disinherited
because of that
uh he lost that firstborn status because
of that it ends up passing to uh Judah
um
because there's also there's also
Absalom yeah Absalom does this uh with
David's wives and concubines During the
period where he
yeah
you serve David's power but uh Absalom
actually did this publicly
he made a public display of it right to
signal to everyone I'm the I'm the head
that he had now taken over
um this is something that um uh was an
attempted
one of the first places where we see the
office of Queen Mother
in the Old Testament is with Solomon has
his mother Bathsheba and thrown into his
right hand and the first person to come
to her and make a request to the king
through her is trying to do this
he requests now that David is gone that
he be given one of David's concubines as
a wife
and Solomon said uh uh I I know where
this is going right so
so this is an epic so this is this
directly is a pattern in the sense of
other people doing this in the context
of a family use or patient
you also see that pattern in other
places
less literally yeah
right so
one of the biggest examples is in
Genesis 3.
um now there's this stuff it Protestant
circles it's called The Serpent Seed
doctrine but there have been Gnostic sex
that thought this and stuff too yeah the
thought that uh Kane was like literally
the son of the son of the devil yeah
that's not what he says that's not what
it says in the Bible though right right
we'd have to be really clear but that's
not based on nothing because there are
these sort of elements of Seduction
in the conversation between the serpent
and Eve yeah yeah but the Bible
functions like that like the Bible also
will not say something like the serpent
slept with with e but because of the
structure of the conversation you
understand that she is submitting
herself to him like she would to her
husband in a way that suggests a kind of
sexual Union without necessarily having
to
like go into the idea that they actually
United sexually by the way this happens
all the way through Bible and in
positive ways too where for example
Christ uh when he meets a Samaritan
woman the entire structure of the
conversation is one of Christ taking her
as a wife but we know that he didn't
marry her and he didn't have he didn't
sleep with her but it's to signify the
meaning of the of the relationship and
so we we have to be careful not to fall
into the same kind of materialism that
we're criticizing when we read these
stories but rather be attentive mostly
to what they're trying to help us
understand of what's going on and let's
say the structure of meaning rather than
just wondering like okay so did Eve
really sleep with the snakes like that's
not what it says in the in the scripture
but but you can understand that that's
what's going on in terms of a
relationship right right that there is
this sort of seductive element and that
after all is what the serpent is trying
to do
it's it's an active user patient yeah
and then in that case it's because he
can't create
right and so this this idea of user
patient
whether it's directly in this family
context or outside of it
right
um is over again sort of the opposite of
it what it's what it's a sin against is
creation
creating something putting something in
which is putting something in order
and filling it with life
right so you look at Abraham right he
builds this family unit
right which has structures people have
roles right within this extended family
which includes not just biological
family members but
sir his servants his herdsmen his right
this whole unit that he's built
and he's filled it with life in the
terms of
I mean most directly in terms of
reproduction right but also it's sort of
the prospering
right of of everyone and and everything
involved
and sort of the shortcut of that is
no I'm not going to build something of
my own I'm not going to participate in
continuing to build this up and fill it
with life and keep it in order
I'm going to try and take it over I'm
going to try and make this thing that
someone else created in mind yeah uh and
that of course is what the devil is
doing right from the beginning God
created it your Insight is perfect so
you can understand that the image of
usurpation itself or the image of the
pride of Satan who wants to you know
even like whatever version of The Fall
of the devil you you take you know
whether it's a kind of miltonian or
virgin or the the the the the more
Ancient One of of the Fall happening at
the at the creation of Adam right in
some ways the idea is that
the devil wants to become Our God you
know like the devil wants to be for us
what is God and then take over take over
creation and that becomes in some ways
make trying to make creation his wife
right it's like that's what the devil is
is always trying to do and that's what
every single Temptation that you face is
trying to do for you right so it's like
with every sin that tempts you is trying
to make you its life you know it's
trying to is trying to come up above and
master everything underneath and and use
it as its body in order to be able to to
grow and to have more power in the world
so it's like a it's a fractal thing that
happens at every level of reality this
idea of of something which wants to come
up usurp and then take the body for
itself
yeah yeah and and
it's important then to also have the
positive
side
right of we're called upon to create
right to build to put in order
right to fill with life and it's
interesting in in sort of the the
popular
Zeitgeist like you look at HBO shows you
have Game of Thrones and then as soon as
it ends you have succession
which is all about children trying to
use serp
and it sees some kind of power something
that was created by sort of a previous
distant father
and all kinds of chaos and Mayhem and
murder and destruction
taking place in that context rather than
anyone trying to build anything
create anything
right bring life to anything yeah yeah
okay so I so then the next step and this
is the one that I don't know what you
think about this yet I kind of wrote you
an email proposed a little bit because
one of the reasons why this story in
particular had my my Fascination was
also because I noticed a pattern in
scripture uh which has to do at the
beginning of something and it seems like
when something begins we always find in
some ways a
we could call a pattern of incest that
is there at the beginning it seems like
in some ways there's the it's like the
sin of the beginning seems to be incest
and the sin of the end seems to be
something like
confusion or going to the strange woman
or that so you we have these two
extremes you could say it's like you
know Solomon's saying don't go to the
strange woman because basically you'll
lose everything like everything will
kind of give be given to the stranger
but then if you look at this the pattern
you see this weird pattern of incest as
the scandal of the beginning so
and that's why when I was looking at
this story I was like that seems to be
what it's referring to but I I always
thought that it was that it was like a
like a homosexual relationship between
ham and Noah but I was like I don't want
to talk about that because it's just
like I and the reason why I see it is
because I want to give people the
examples it's like in Genesis after
Sodom and Gomorrah you have lot who
sleeps with his daughters then you have
at the at the when God reveals himself
to Abraham you find that Abraham also is
married to his sister like his
half-sister which is which would be
which would be a sin like which would be
a something that would be prohibited in
the in the law later
um and then when you when you so you so
you have Noah you have lot then you have
Abraham right right there in Genesis
these three iterations of the beginnings
of worlds uh where there seems to be
this this this Trope and then when you
bring it into Genesis then you have it
right at the beginning and now it's like
obviously it's not it's not a sin at
this point but you have the idea that
you know Eve is taken from Adam and his
his own is his own uh body basically
it's like it's him that is that is taken
out out of him and so and so now when
you when you say when you bring When you
mention you said No it's it's really
based on the law what you see in the law
which is that there's a relationship
with Noah's mother or Noah's wife and
then the descendants of that occurs I'm
like yeah then that it fits it even
better with the way that I saw it it
kind of kind of makes this a pattern
that repeats all over all over Genesis
so I don't know if you've noticed that
or what do you think about my perception
yeah
so part of
there's also another corresponding Trope
on the other side
and that is so if incest is too close
yeah right it's sort of joining the same
with the same right yeah then you also
have the Trope with Esau right where
they go and you know Abraham is very
concerned with Isaac that he not marry
one of the people of the land yeah
right yeah even in even in Abraham you
have the same thing where he wants to
find the right distance so for his sons
he wants his sons to marry like a cousin
or like a second cousin or something
yeah
then it will it will basically take all
your strength away into the stranger if
it's too close then it creates this
weird internal Loop that it will that
will cause absolute chaos yeah it brings
about this sort of chaos of Destruction
and so both of those
right you see set out as these as these
polarities yeah and that really goes
back to Adam and Eve
right and the whole idea
when Eve is created
as in Hebrew the eights are connecto and
conego really
it means fits together like puzzle
pieces
right
um you know there's a literal very
literal material biological yeah sense
like puzzle pieces but it goes beyond
that right it's not limited to that
um
and so
the idea that yeah she is not she is
bone of Adam's bone and flesh of his
flesh
but at the same time
right she is full in the places he's
empty right and right and so that is the
place where there is this sort of
the sort of perfect connection
right that then is able to sort of
produce life
and produce uh
good order yeah right so in the
incestuous relationship can produce life
but but not order yeah it's a new
supreme because it actually creates
confusion and this is Technic it's
technically true like it it because the
world has an order of manifestation
right it's like a father with a mother
and then children and then you know the
father has relationship like sisters and
brothers at this level and then the
children come down but if a child has a
relationship with someone that is you
know at the same level as their father
either their father or their mother or
some or like an uncle or whatever then
then the relationships become actually
confused the identity of the people
become confused because what is the
child the child is the child my brother
is he my son is he my is he my uncle
like what is this child it's it's it's
now creating confusion in the the order
of reality itself it's like it's it's
literally doing that when you when you
when you break the normal order of
causality of the world right and and you
end up destroying what you're trying to
user exactly that's what you're trying
to gain control of yeah which is the
very pattern of Revolution itself you
see that that's what that's what happens
like in the in the cosmogony you have a
very powerful image of it which is that
you know it's like you know Saturn
castrates his father but then he has to
eat his children
because he's created now a confusion of
order that makes it that he's not afraid
of his own children because it's like
they are they are not in the right
relationship with with him they're going
to come to get him and he doesn't know
what to do and so you have this you have
this this confusion that that yeah that
self basically like that self-destroys
at some ultimately yeah yeah and it
becomes
again rather than producing life it
becomes parasitic yeah it drains it away
yeah so so and and it's interesting
because my my brother mentioned this in
his interview with Jordan Peterson like
how he said all the scripture is about
that like all the scriptures about
finding
the right distance like the right wife
you could say like between that which is
too close and that which is too far
right the the the the stranger that
loves you ultimately you could say which
is not as not a stranger that's so far
that they'll kind of swallow you up and
if you take that Trope now that we
mentioned and we see that it's there
this idea of you don't want to go to the
strange woman because she'll bring your
gods in and then you'll be usurped also
in that way but you also don't want to
be too close because you create this
confusion of identity
in Christ you have this weird
Transcendence of all these things you
have this way in which it all kind of
gets expanded and collapsed at the same
time first of all the Samaritan woman I
think seems to be a direct
uh reference to this question because
one of the things Christ does is first
of all he talks about the well and the
the fountain which is the image that
Solomon uses when he talks about this
strange woman
he he he he says like keep your fountain
to yourself don't let it run into the
streets and and he uses this images of
Wells and and the fountains to talk
about not going towards the strange
woman and then cries basically is the is
the only one
who can marry the strange woman
but not be taken over by her
right he can go to the ends of the world
he can go all the way to the edge but
he's never
subsumed by the strained woman
well that's and
I think the reason for that is the
Incarnation
part of the theme when you read the
prophets and they're describing the
relationship between
God and Israel
and why that doesn't work is that
they're too different
they're too far apart
and you look at the analogies there the
way Israel is described it's always as
sort of this Foreigner
you know who God finds in the desert you
know
um and and Mary's right but it's it's
too far apart but
this is why calcene is so important
right Christ is is consubstantial with
the father according to his divinity and
consubstantial with us
yeah and you can see that in some ways
it's it's because one of the things that
I've noticed when we did this whole
seminar in Exodus and in the seminar at
Exodus you can see the problem
constantly of mediation that God is
constantly conceding mediations but he
like it's almost like he knows that this
is going to cause problems in the long
run it's like oh you know you know you
want Aaron but then Aaron makes the
golden calf you know okay so now you
have all these laws and it's complicated
and then you see you know and then later
in Samuel he's like oh you don't want a
king like why would you want if you want
a king all this mediation is gonna is
gonna turn against you but in some ways
God's constantly conceding it because he
knows that it's inevitable because of
this problem of distance then ultimately
Christ ends up being the the key to the
whole problem from the beginning of
mediation right and so and so Christ can
make that marriage work
yeah and so that's why so Pentecost is
like so so when Prophet say you know one
day the spirit of God will be poured out
on All Flesh it's like you can imagine
how weird that sounds even to people who
now have been told to not marry the
strange woman to not go to the stranger
to not but they it's like they know that
ultimately at some point you know this
marriage will be a universal marriage
will be a married with all of humanity
but then how is that possible
considering this problem of of distance
you could say yeah yeah and so Humanity
has to become bone of God's bone and
flesh of God's flesh yeah like Eve was
to Adam
and so then this is this is to me
because this is something that I've seen
uh us a few like uh writers try to take
on because when we look at the symbolism
of the mother of God in in in
Christianity we have this weird thing
going on right which is exactly the
symbolism that I'm a TR that I'm talking
about which is that she's represented
both as Christ's mother and as Christ's
bride so you have this sent in which
it's suggesting a weird like ancestral
thing
uh and but then when you realize what is
actually happening even if you use the
image of the Samaritan woman as the
example you realize it that Christ is in
some ways he's beyond that Dua like he
he doesn't have that problem he's kind
of he's kind of transforming the whole
question you know and of course I'm not
suggesting in any way that there was
something inappropriate between Jesus
then right and Mary what I'm saying is
that the symbolism that's being kind of
expanded is that ultimately those two
you know in
in in Christ are kind of that problem is
is transcended somehow
yeah and part of
part of the problem with that frankly is
the modern
American and maybe broader Western sort
of obsession with
sexual relations like proper the
material sense yeah well that's why we
can't see the the pattern if it's not
like that's why I people will struggle
to say well the serpent is trying to
seduce Eve and it's like I'm not
suggesting the serpent slept with even
some weird material way but I'm just
showing you that this these patterns
they have different iterations you know
yeah but this is and this is
this is the problem with the augustinian
treatment frankly of human sexuality is
that it fails to see
physical sexuality as the material
signifier
of a spiritual reality
that remains regardless of
the presence of that material signifier
so what I mean by that is
and I've said this to people in marriage
counseling a lot
right if you have a a you know 23 year
old couple who just got married
and you have uh an 83 year old couple
that's been married for 60 years
right uh the 23 year old couple is
having a lot hotter sex
right that's a lot more often probably
yes
but the 83 year old couple
right has a relationship
at a deeper level that goes far beyond
that yeah
right far far far beyond that yeah in
some ways and also kind of in in that
physical aspect of it let's say kind of
uh
fading away they capture the pure the
Pearl like they they're they're they're
moving into the into the deeper part of
what of what it is that they were moving
towards in the first place and those two
are not unrelated exactly they're
directly related yeah right
but the one is this sort of material
signifier yeah right of the of the
deeper reality and so but every time we
think about any of these Concepts
our contemporary Minds move immediately
to just the material signifier right
it's just
you know
titillation and you know
oh you're you're talking about sex like
no we're talking about the reality
behind that right
yeah and so in some ways what it
requires of us is really a complete
reversal of the way we think of what is
real you know and it's not a because we
tend to We tend to
and you see it most people today even
you know they tend to like oppose oppose
normally the spiritual and the material
they oppose it and so either they fall
into one or the other either they wanted
to to kind of uh you know poo poo the
the the material practice and the
material world and want to live just in
the spirit you know like people who say
I'm spiritual but not religious that
kind of that kind of that kind of
nonsense uh and then on the other hand
you know we have people who think that
that you know this material world is so
real like that's what we need to chase
after but both of those are are a
mistake you know ultimately to see it in
this scale of hierarchy where the
physical materiality is the bottom part
and the most the most let's say
immediate But ultimately has to move us
into what its height or what it's not
hiding in the bad sense but what it what
it holds in its Center like what's
holding it together
what lies behind it yeah yeah and again
what lies behind it is there even if you
want to try to deny it
like people who live very promiscuously
that does things to your heart and to
your soul over time yeah because
you can't be intimate with people
physically and not also have developed
intimate Connections in other ways yeah
like leave some part of your soul like
with that person yeah
um so because they're so
intricately bound together yeah
and and you know and I think that it's
not the the way that the church
represents our Union you know is not
arbitrary and the way that the reason
why we insist on marriage is not just
some kind of moral finger wagging right
it is it is and you can see like people
who live prom with promise Q with a lot
of promiscuity in their life and
especially people that that you know
obviously don't come to repentance they
don't come to kind of a transformation
you know they they they end with
bitterness like it's hard not for that
not not to happen yeah and repentance
again is not like feeling bad and and
whipping yourself or pens is being
healed yeah from the damage that's been
done
you know and and yeah so there there
sort of is there is hope for that yeah
and and
part of that part of the problem with
the way we talk about marriage now is
that we've got this very modern idea of
the nuclear family
behind it yeah and that conception of
marriage and family leaves a lot of
people out
and has caused us a lot of problems so
I'm a big Advocate as people who
Listen to Lord of spirits to know I
describe it as arguing for the abolition
of the nuclear family just to get
everybody
freaked out but
um that we need to come back to within
our church communities and things a more
robust idea of family like the kind of
families we see in Genesis of extended
family
you know that includes a lot that is is
able to include a lot of people it's
able to include an adult who for
whatever reason has not gotten married
yeah because
it doesn't mean like I
I understand what you're saying but the
the the the nuclear family should I
would see this I'd rather see it as like
the nuclear family should be just
expanded into this right for an expanded
family to exist you need
someone to have been a strong nuclear
family and then be able to like expand
that like breathe out and to include the
uncle that like you said didn't get
married or like whatever someone who got
divorced or some you know someone who
died and the child gets up ends up kind
of going to their brother or whatever
like that has to be something that has
to in order for us to to be able to live
in that more expanded way definitely
yeah I think the older
the much older what what family meant
for most of human history yeah has just
been ground down to the nuclear family
definitely
you know and and I think right now so
much effort is put into trying to
preserve that little bit that's left
that we really need to redirect into
rebuilding um
not just trying to preserve what the
culture and Society has left us but
build out build back and build out from
there again
so I I have another question that just
to get back to the to the NOAA story and
everything do you think there's do you
think or do you see a relationship
between the way that also you're
interpreting first of all the sort of
Noah then also the the the story the way
that we talk about the fall of the the
idea of the Nephilim and all this
question that when Saint Paul talks
about the covering you know that weird
that weird sentence when Saint Paul says
you know that that women should wear
coverings for the sake of the Angels do
you think that there's a relationship
between this idea of uncovering and and
the the union let's say in that sense
yes
can you help us work that out a little
bit yeah yeah because we all have that
intuition but it's fuzzy like it's a
fuzzy it's a fuzzy thing yeah we're
gonna get into all the really wild stuff
here in this one video
um
so there's a phrase that Saint Paul uses
in that context
that's often translated in English
symbol of authority
um so uh the word there
I'll go ahead and say it the word there
is the Greek word for scrotum
yeah I didn't want to know that so
um and so part of what's going on there
is uh Saint Paul seems to be referencing
uh
Greco-Roman medical tax
so the uh
understanding in Roman medicine
um and you see this if you read how
Saint John chrysostom deals with this
path the larger Passage
you can see it reflected in what he says
too
um but if you go and read like the
Hippocratic Corpus
uh they believe that hair
uh served as sort of a receptacle
for male seed
that it was sort of drawn up into the
body
by by hair okay and
therefore so a woman who wore her hair
long
and exposed was presenting herself as
sexually available
and likewise a man who wore his hair
long
culturally was considered to be
presenting himself as sexually available
to other men
and that's why I say Paul says having
long hair is a shame right to a man and
you're going well wait a minute what
about nazarites instead right he's not
referring to that he's talking about
this thing in this context right
and so uh because of that
essentially a woman's long hair
was seen as a genital structure that's
why he can use that word
right to to refer to it and so to have
that exposed
In Worship
right
would be presenting oneself as sort of
sexually available within the context of
worship he's writing this to Corinth
where to be super blunt most of the
religious festivals were accompanied by
orgies
right
and saying there is there is no place
for that Within
right to the Christian worship context
and then is referencing in terms of the
because of the Angels is referencing
back to the idea of the Nephilim yeah
right which
proceeded as you mentioned earlier out
of this ritual context
yeah which is happening which is a
ritual context in the worship like they
are in the ritual context there and so
there's like a conclusion placing
yourself as available to receive the
influence of higher States but not being
properly covered so that you could
become like a
you could become like a receptacle for
the wrong like for for the let's say for
the
yeah for for for the intermediary beings
you could say it that way maybe right
this is and this is the ability to bring
life into the world is a power that
women possess yeah that needs to be
protected because of how powerful it is
yeah and so I mean it makes it it's
complex because it's working it's
working on mall it's working on all
these multiple levels at the same time
because in some ways we can understand
it something like if you were going to
be very boring about it we could say
something like
if the woman is uncovered in in this in
the in this in the context of worship in
a religious ritual she is opening
herself to influences that are that
would be kind of these free-floating
intermediary influences you know that
aren't right God himself that are kind
of like this kind of intermediary world
that's messy and and full of mixture of
Angels and Demons or whatever uh and
that
and that in some ways that would be
dangerous for her dangerous for the
church dangerous for
yeah right and
and Noah's sinned then in the case is
not just oh he got drunk and embarrassed
himself
somehow he got drunk and did something
embarrassing which you know you
shouldn't do but in terms of like severe
sins right not probably top of most
people's list
his his sin is
being drunk and inebriated right on on
the good things of this world and
failing to protect
right the the the his nakedness right
yeah
the team is there because Lord gets
drunk before he before it before it's
right he passes out and yeah or his
daughters and so there's like a there's
definitely a narrative relationship
between the two and and I think that
it's because iconographically like we
represent it straightforwardly and so if
you if you have an iconographic
representation of the scene you will see
you will see like a Vine you'll see Noah
drunk asleep and then you'll see ham
like
pointing at his nakedness usually and
then you'll see like the two the two
sons walking backwards you know with
like a sheet or something and I think
that it's it's completely appropriate to
kind of take it at the first level
especially if we're going to represent
it visually but if you want to
understand how it relates to the rest of
the Bible and how it relates you know to
all these these moments of beginnings
and all these moments of transgression
all the way into Christ and we have to
see that it's more than just this kind
of like this kind of weird thing because
if you think about it like you know it
it's like anything right you you think
okay so all of Canaan is cursed like the
whole not just the Sun but like the
whole descendants of Canaan is cursed
because his father saw
his own father naked it's like man
that's rough that's a that's a rough
thing
but that's also see that's a so the the
father-son thing yeah in scripture is
always talking about
repeating the pattern yeah
right so the Canaanites had come and
laid claim to this land
that belonged to God and that was not
their inheritance
it was someone else's inheritance that's
right yeah so it repeats it in the in
the context of the two peoples right
yeah and so that that that pattern
repeats yeah in the lock case the the
idea of him failing to protect his
daughters is really brought out leading
up to that because if you read closely
in the story he had betrothed both of
them to Men of Sodom that's right yeah
and he basically he proposed to
basically like to throw him out there
man right to give them to the Mob right
and and so yeah that final episode right
is uh of this has this really it's a
reversal of outgrowth for sin like it's
like it's almost like it's a pendulum
where she was willing to give his
daughters up to these these destructive
men and that was like the sin of the too
far you could say and also this this and
then finally turns back on him and then
he becomes the father of his own
grandchildren you know right right yeah
Abraham is so concerned he wants to find
Isaac a wife from his own people whereas
lot is just like
a couple of the guys here in town
you guys can marry them that's why
that's fine yeah
well and especially in that sense
because you also see in the
in uh they're already in Genesis you
have this image where
uh would it have more who wants to marry
into Jacob's family and says if we marry
their daughters then we'll basically
take them over like it'll take a while
but you know at some point we'll just
take whatever they have because we'll
just keep taking their daughters and
then we'll overwhelm them and then
they'll they'll basically disappear and
stop sort of assimilate them yeah
exactly you know and so it's like that's
the image that Solomon tries to bring
about when he talks about marrying the
strange woman or the idea of the strange
Gods like you you have to find that
balance so that you're not swallowed up
by the by the outside yeah I don't want
to sound like I'm making this trite but
you can apply this at every level of
structure that we're involved with like
I say you you have any kind of team you
know it's like and you're doing
something like if you just constantly
circulate within yourself like you know
it's like you're just constantly
everybody is always with inside the team
in a way that at some point
you know just becomes circular you're
gonna break down like if you do that for
a while it's gonna break down at some
point you won't be able to but if you
just like go on the street and just hire
anybody just go out and like oh you you
you you you're not doing anything why
don't you come work on our team then you
run the risk of becoming you have to
find that balance between you know what
we're doing and Innovation or new or New
Blood and and so you have to kind of
find you're always trying to find that
balance between that which will
invigorate the team but won't you know
basically take its identity away in the
long term yeah well I think it's even I
think it's even true at the level of
the human soul
we're very much now able with the
internet for example to put ourselves
into an echo chamber yeah where we only
ever talk to people who endorse
everything we ever say do and think
you know who agree with us about
everything
right right now that's exactly right you
know and the solution to that is not the
opposite is not to just expose yourself
to everything and
be completely credulous and believe
anything anyone tells you and sort of
sell everything out but there's again
the the middle distance yeah
right yeah and you can see when you
don't do that what happens like there's
a the this is a weird example but it's
the one that comes to my mind which is
that there's an interesting debate
online among debate between
uh it's like Matt tabi and I forget I
forget his name and like Malcolm
Gladwell right and yeah I've actually
heard that you see that it's about media
capture and you can tell that the
Malcolm Gladwell side
was so much in their Echo chamber yeah
that they didn't even understand the
arguments of the of their opponents and
so they kind of they were just in this
illusion of their coherent world and
then their world just got shattered on
stage like smashed into visas and they
lost the debate by the the biggest
margin anybody's ever lost a monk debate
and they don't they still don't
understand why that happened because
it's like they're so into their own like
uh and so you can actually see it it's
like it's actually even as a Christian
let's say
and if you just have these weird like
internal things like that you're just
talking to other Orthodox Christians and
all you talk about are like Divine
energies like all day and then and then
you haven't ever you haven't encountered
anybody from the outside you haven't
discussed with with anybody outside then
at some point when you when you're
challenged you'll just you'll shatter
yeah there's no there's no creative
power in that yeah
that's never going to go anywhere
produce anything new right give life to
anything yeah anything living yeah yeah
exactly all right this is this is
wonderful I mean we really went right to
the edge there if I was keeping
yeah I'm pretty sure you were going to
try and monetize this so that's probably
good
it's like that I I didn't expect you to
use you to wear use the word scrotum in
our discussion but there you go that's
that's how it goes and so I and so thank
you for your time thank you also for
everything you do and and everybody I am
also you know and I'm really excited to
have you uh talk to us at the symbolic
World Summit it's going to be it's going
to be amazing and don't forget people
also to look out for this mock World
Journal which will have his uh father
Stephen's uh Exposition about this very
question in printed in the journal so so
a lot of great things coming on the
horizon is there something you're
working on that you want to give us a
peek on or um
well Lord Lord willing the next book
I've been doing this big project on
Saint Paul
so sort of from an orthodox perspective
so that's probably the next thing
in print you'll see coming all right
that sounds cool that'll probably be
sometime next year
wonderful all right thank you Father
Stephen it's great to talk to you